الموضوع من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي يرحب بك
السيد الياس معنا اذا ضمن اي تكتيك تاتي
هذه الضربه الجديده على جسر القرن
سفيان يجب النظر الى الواقع الميداني الذي
تعاني فيه اوكرانيا من التعثر في الهجوم
واحد وهذا امر قاله رئيس الاركان ووزير
الدفاع في تغيير التكتيك والحق في ضرب اي
منطقه حتى في العمق الروسي وفي العمق
المحتل اليوم التكتيك تبدل الى ضرب
الاهداف ذات القيمه الاستراتيجيه في عمق
الدفاعات الروسيه والتي لها علاقه مباشره
باللوجستيه لماذا لان الجيش الروسي يعتمد
على اللوجستيه وخاصه الذخائر بشكل كبير
اثنين التكتيك الاخر هو بسبب كثره الالغام
على جبهه طولها 900 كيلومتر بدا الجيش
الاوكراني بدل استعمال كاسحات الالغام
استعمال المشاه من سلاح الهندسه لنزع هذه
الالغام وهذا امر صعب جدا اليوم ان تضرب
هدف بهذه الاهميه سفيان شيء خطير جدا
لماذا
اكتوبر الماضي تعرض نفس الجسر لحادث اكبر
من هذه المره فاذا هناك فشل تكتيكي فشل
استخباراتي وفشل في حمايه الاهداف ذات
القيمه الاستراتيجيه العاليه ومن اين ياتي
هذا الفشل سيد العميد يعني ما هو اهم عامل
تفتقره القوات الروسيه في التصدي لهذه
الهجمات
الجيش الجيش الروسي ليلى يعاني منذ فتره
طويله يعني بعد حاله التمرد هناك تغيير
على سبيل المثال في القيادات العسكريه
منهم من شكل الى سوريا منهم من حقق معه
واقيل من منصبه ومنهم من اقف وهذه امور
تضرب معنويات الجيش ككل يعني في اداره
الازمه حتى العمل الاستخباراتي قبل البدء
بالهجوم ب 22 شباط 2022 كان هناك خطا في
تقييم وتقدير هذه الامور اليوم اذا استطعت
اوكرانيا ان تقصف عن بعد اقرب مركز
اوكراني لهذا الجسر يبعد ال300 كم وليس
لدى اوكرانيا هذا السلاح الستورم شادو 250
كم فقط حتى اذا كانت العمليه قريبه من
خلال مسيرات هذا الامر يعتبر فشل
استراتيجي بغض النظر عن الوسيله وبغض
النظر عن النتيجه المهم هو الصوره التي
تعكسها ضرب جسر قرش وهو من المهم من اهم
الجسور وهو طفل الرئيس بوتين يعتبره هو
انجازاته الاساسيه طيب يعني العميد الياس
يعني هذا الاستهداف وما سبقه في نفس
المنطقه في القرن تحديدا يعني طالما وصف
بالاستهداف المحدود بالتالي ما اهميه هذه
الضربه وما مستوى الارباك ربما على الصعيد
اللوجستي تحديدا الذي قد يتسبب بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه
تحدثتم خلال النشره حاليا عن تعدد
الاستهدافات في شبه جزيره القرم شبه جزيره
قلم هي القاعده الاساسيه لكل الجنوب
الاوكراني وهي مهمه جدا لوجستيان من
القواعد البحريه الى القواعد الاساسيه منذ
فتره تم استهداف جسر شنهار جسر الذي يصل
شبه جزيره قرن بمدينه خرسون كوي ايضا في
نفس الوقت فاذا هذا الاستهداف هو عمليه
ارباك هو عمليه تاخير يعني اليوم الطريق
البديل لكارش هو عبر كراس نضار رستوف
وبالتالي باتجاه الغرب الى خرسون وهي طريق
طويله وتصبح اكثر عرضه للاستافات الاساسيه
من قبل اوكرانيا هذا التخطيط العسكري هو
يعني بدائي الى حد ما وتكرر وعند التكرار
يعني ان هناك فشل في اداره الازمه
العسكريه من الناحيه التكتيكيه الى
العملانيه وحتى الى الاستراتيجيه سفيان
اشكرك العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس
حنا من بيروت